So you're paying for his attorney,
for his kids?
Like for that whole thing?
What? I don't get it.
What do you mean?
Oh my gosh, yeah,
of course I'm helping him.
That woman he was with was so evil,
she left him homeless,
bankrupt, with nothing.
He needs somebody to help him get back on his feet.
He's an amazing father.
Of course I'm gonna pay for his attorney
to fight for his kids.
What are you talking about?
What? I mean, it just.
It sounds like it's like a really risky move
cause it's like a lot of money.
And if he's homeless and unemployed,
like, I don't see how that has really anything to do
with the woman he was just dating.
Like the mother of his children.
It seems like that's
totally separate from why he's in a situation he's in.
And it feels like
maybe he's just trying to drag you down and like,
use up all your money.
Aren't you afraid of that?
I knew you were jealous of our relationship.
And he told me that you would have something to say
like this. He's seen you
and what kind of friend you are to me.